الاث رئيس الوزراء عن الجهود المتواصله
لافراج عن الرهائن ولكن هذه الصفقه لن
تاتي على حساب اي اثمان اخرى وفيما يتعلق
بالوضع في الشمال الهجمات متواصله انتهاكا
للقرار الاممي
171 ولكن كان هناك اجتماع مع اموس هوسين
ولقد عبرنا عن استعداد اسرائيل لحل
هذه التوترات بالطرق الدبلوماسيه والسيد
دانييل غاري تحدث عن جهود اسرائيل لردع
عدوان حزب الله وذلك يشمل جهود دفاعيه على
الحدود
وا ايضا جهود للدفاع عن النفس وردع قدرات
حزب الله وزياده الاستعداد لحرب على
الحدود الشماليه يمكنكم ان نظ الى بيان
الادميرال دانيل هاجي حول ذلك
و اليوم رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
التقى
ب جنود من الكتيبه 179 ولقد اكد ان
اسرائيل لا تزال تصر على الانتصار التام
على حماس وهذا الامر سيكون ضربه كبيره
لمحور ايران للشر واذا هذا الامر ضروري
لكي نتمكن من
تكيد ضمان حصول اتفاقيات
سلام مستقبليه وليس هناك اي بديل لهذا
النصر اسرائيل تعمل على تحقيق هذا الهدف
العسكري رئيس الوزراء قال اننا لن نتوقف
عن الحرب بدون الانتصار وبدون استعاده
الامن على الحدود الشماليه والجنوبيه
والان ننتقل الى
الاسئله يطلب رئيس الوزراء من وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي اقناع
ال السلطات المصريه بمسائل متعلقه
بالاوضاع على معبر
رفح لقد قال رئيس الوزراء البارحه في
الاجتماع مع الحكومه انه سبق وفكك 17 من
بين 24 كتيبه لحماس ونحن سوف نواصل
التركيز على القوه المتبقيه في جنوب قطاع
غزه نحن نركز على تدمير كل المجموعات
التابعه لحماس في قطاع غزه ونريد ان ننزع
السلاح كليا لكي نقضي على اي تهديد قد
يهدد اسرائيل في المستقبل بقا حماس في اي
مكان في قطاع غزه و زعزعتها للاستقرار لا
يصب بمصلحه اي
احد
السؤال كان متعلقا بالرئيس عن رئيس
ارجنتينا ليس لدي اي معلومات عن ذلك سؤال
اخر هل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والمملكه المتحده تحدثكم او تعطيكم
معلومات عن الهجمات الاخرى في المنطقه
اسرائيل تواصل الحديث العسكري مع الحلفاء
وهجمات الحوثيين ضد الملاحه الدوليه هي
تهديد على الملاحه الدوليه والتجاره
الدوليه واذا يجب ان يكون الرد دولي
سؤال من ه
جوليان
المصارف الاسرائيليه جمدت حسابات اشخاص
تعرضوا لعقوبات امريكيه هل سيكون هناك
اجراءات اخرى اذا لم ترضى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على الاجراءات التي
تتخذها في الضفه الغربيه رئيس الوزراء سبق
ورد على هذا السؤال فيما يتعلق بالقرار
التنفيذي الذي اصدره الرئيس رئ بايدن ولقد
قال ان اغلبيه السكان في الضفه الغربيه
يحترمون القانون واسرائيل تتصرف ضد اي شخص
ينتهك القانون وهذه الاجراءات ضروريه هذا
كان تعليق رئيس الوزراء ولم يكن هناك اي
تعليق اخر سؤال ثاني من هانا
جوليان هل
حكومه اسرائيل تتشارك تفاؤل السيد هوك
شتاين فيما يتعلق بردع
حزب الله في الشمال نحن نتحلى بالواقعيه
فيما يتعلق بردع حزب الله ونحن نتحلى
بالواقعيه ايضا فيما يتعلق بالجهود
لابعاد حزب الله عن الحدود الشماليه نحن
نامل انه سيكون هناك حل دبلوماسي ولذلك
نحن الان نسعى لهذا الحل الدبلوماسي ولكن
كنا واضحين
ان المهله الزمنيه للتوصل الى هذا الحل
الدبلوماسي
اصبحت اكثر واكثر واذا سيكون هناك عمل
لاستعاده او اعاده السكان الى شمال
اسرائيل
وسنعمل على ردع حزب الله على الحدود
الشماليه وهناك تهديد
ل تكرر احداث السابع من اكتوبر
هناك هل هناك مقترح على الطاوله فيما
يتعلق بحل مع حزب الله لاعاده الى
الشمال وزير الدفاع التقى بالسيد هوشين
لتحدث عن طرق ل تفادي التصعيد والسعي الى
حل دبلوماسي نحن نفضل الحل الدبلوماسي
والسيد هوكين تحدث معنا عن هذه المصالح
المشتركه لنا وللولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فيما يتعلق باعاده السكان الى شمال
اسرائيل
اذا شكرا لكم جميعا لقد انتهينا
اليوم